bonsoir je pense qu'il est absolument
nécessaire d'aller au théâtre
pourquoi il est nécessaire parce que
c'est inutile
le théâtre est nécessaire parce qu'il
est inutile pour éclaircir ce paradoxe
je vais vous raconter une anecdote
personnelle quand j'étais enfant j'avais
un petit vélo et je faisais comme si
c'était une grosse moto je mettais mon
casque en plastique et j'imitais avec ma
bouche le rugissement du moteur pour
faire pendant des heures le tour du
jardin de mes parents quand j'ai eu 18
ans j'ai découvert avec bonheur les
vraies sensations procurées par la
vitesse et par les vibrations du moteur
entre mes jambes
j'adore la moto mais je n'ai jamais
retrouvé l'intensité du plaisir que
j'avais proulx éprouvé enfants en rêvant
que j'étais sur une moto jouer à être
sur une moto est resté toujours une
expérience beaucoup plus excitante que
simplement faire de la moto ce jeu qui
transformait mon vélo en moto et est
pourtant tout à fait inutile dans la
mesure où je ne [ __ ] est pas moins
fort et je n'avançais pas plus vite
mais les histoires que je me racontais
m'était nécessaire pour décupler les
sensations que j'éprouve est dans la
réalité
pour retrouver cette ivresse
j'avais le choix entre la drogue et le
théâtre
j'ai choisi et voilà maintenant trente
ans que je consacre ma vie assez tard
inutile mais nécessaire nécessaire et
inutiles sont deux mots que tout semble
opposer
il est nécessaire de manger et dormir
pour vivre ou survivre
il est inutile c'est ce qui nous arrache
à cette nécessité première c'est ce qui
nous permet de nous construire de nous
épanouir et de jouir pleinement de nos
capacités d'être sensible et intelligent
c'est le domaine de l'imaginaire du
plaisir en ce sens le théâtre est
inutile mais il est aussi absolument
nécessaire le théâtre et elle est
nécessaire justement parce qu'il est
inutile
je vais maintenant vous parler de deux
personnes toutes deux disparu récemment
mais qui continue à beaucoup compté dans
ma vie de tous les jours
l'une s'appelle steve jobbs l'autre
s'appelle patrice chéreau inutile de
vous présenter le premier mais il est
nécessaire que j'explique à ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas que patrice chéreau a
réalisé plusieurs films pour le cinéma
qu'il était aussi acteur et surtout un
très grand metteur en scène de théâtre
et d'opéra steve jobbs a développé et
commercialisé un outil qui connecte en
permanence des milliards d'individus sur
la planète
patrice chéreau a créé une oeuvre qui
s'est inscrite profondément dans la
mémoire de quelques milliers de
spectateurs qui ont pu voir ces films ou
ses spectacles
tous deux ont contribué à augmenter
notre réalité l'un avec des logiciels et
des applications qui raccourcissent le
temps et les distances l'autre avec des
textes et les acteurs qui élargissent
nos perceptions et notre réflexion
les inventions de steve jobbs nous sont
devenus presque aussi nécessaire que
manger dormir nous serions totalement
démuni sans ces extensions numérique qui
nous ont poussé au bout des doigts pour
nous plonger dans un flux ininterrompu
des changes professionnelles
personnelles voire sexuelle et qui
génère par la même occasion des profits
financiers colossaux l'économie du
théâtre n'a aucune comparaison avec ces
géants d'internet et l'audiovisuel
une étude récente montré que une bonne
audience d'une seule soirée de
télévision 10 à 12 millions de
téléspectateurs équivalait à dix années
de programmation à la comédie française
et pourtant les quelques spectateurs qui
ont eu l'occasion de voir la dispute une
pièce de marivaux mise en scène par
patrice chéreau en 1976 en parle encore
aujourd'hui comme d'une expérience
inoubliable et qui les a marqué
profondément je n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de côtoyer steve jobbs mais
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer patrice
chéreau parce qu'il m'engager dans mon
premier spectacle en tant qu acteur
professionnel
il m'a ouvert un monde à la démesure de
mes sensations d'enfants sur mon petit
vélo ou sur mon petit vélo j'ai compris
que l'on pouvait élaboré dans la boîte
noire d'un théâtre des fictions qui
donnait de la valeur et du sens à ma
réalité
j'ai aussi pris conscience que ces
histoires partagées en direct avec le
public avait des résonances intimes en
chacun des spectateurs
j'ai donc continué mon chemin de
comédiens puis de metteur en scène et
depuis quelques années de directeur du
théâtre olympia à tours où j'ai décidé
de monter cette année
la dispute de marivaux
ce spectacle mythique de patrice chéreau
que je n'avais pas pu voir parce que
j'étais encore en âge de jouer à la moto
sur mon petit vélo avaient voyagé dans
mon imaginaire jusqu'à s'imposer comme
une étape nécessaire de mon parcours
quarante ans après sa création ma
mémoire a reconstitué un spectacle
d'autant plus beau que je ne l'avais
jamais vu et qui était devenu une source
d'inspiration formidable je crois que le
théâtre est un art du présent qui se
nourrit du passé pour mieux envisager
l'avenir
le théâtre nous invite à débrancher nos
smartphones à rompre avec l'agitation
frénétique dans laquelle nous vivons
pour nous laisser emporter vers d'autres
réalités
contrairement aux produits de
consommation courante auquel nous sommes
habitués
le théâtre ne vise pas la satisfaction
immédiate d'un désir le plaisir est une
composante essentielle du théâtre mais
elle n'est pas la seule
le théâtre peut bousculer bouleversé
choqué voire exaspéré le théâtre n'est
pas là pour
répondre à la satisfaction d'une attente
le théâtre est là pour proposer quelque
chose qu'on ne connaît pas les
spectateurs qui s'achemine les uns après
les autres dans les salles obscures sont
réunis par l'espoir secret de découvrir
non pas ce qu'ils connaissent
mais ce qu'ils n'ont jamais vu ni
entendu ni ressenti le théâtre n'est pas
là pour apporter des réponses en ce sens
il est inutile mais le théâtre est
nécessaire parce qu'ils nous posent des
questions merci